ahora sí llegó el momento que tanto
estabas esperando vamos a formar las
antenas para nuestro robot entonces
vamos a desdoblar
el clip
y después vamos a doblarlo a esta forma
así
dejando uno de los extremos del clip
derecho para colocar el pegamento
caliente entonces este lado que yo dejé
derecho es el que voy a usar para
pegarlo al robot así que aquí está la
pistola para derretir el silicon
entonces colocaré un poco de silicón
caliente sobre el clip pongo un poco de
silicón caliente en esta parte del clip
la parte que deje derecha y ya que hice
eso voy a sostener el clip por un
momento en este lugar para que así quede
en el sitio ya que ya que el silicona
haya enfriado entonces esperamos un poco
a que el silicón enfríe mientras
sostenemos el clip en ese lugar
esperamos un poco y debe estar listo en
un momento entonces ya que está listo
hacemos exactamente lo mismo con la otra
antena tomamos el clip lo desdoblamos
después lo doblamos a la forma que
queremos para formar la antena y le
ponemos un poco de silicón caliente en
esa parte que dejamos derecha ahí es
donde le pondremos el silicón caliente
al clip
y después tienes que esperar
tienes que sostenerlo así
que no se mueva
tienes que sostenerlo y bueno
así que falta algo de paciencia pero no
tardó tanto en secar el pegamento
ahí ya ya quedó más o menos entonces
bueno ahí está
ya casi seca esto
y si derramas un poco de pegamento no
importa cuándo seque lo puedes cortar
con las tijeras no te preocupes por eso
muy bien entonces bueno vemos que esto
funciona ya tenemos las dos antenas en
su lugar y puedes darle forma doblando
las un poco pero por el momento así está
bien entonces ahora sólo falta realizar
una última conexión que es la que
llevara corriente a los ojos de luces
led y usaremos este interruptor para
encender y apagar las luces entonces
bueno debes hacer debes hacer un lazo
que se acomoda en este polo y puedes
utilizar las pinzas de punta porque
observa que bueno el lazo si el lazo es
demasiado grande se sale del polo
ajá como por ejemplo ahorita en vez
entonces hay que tener cuidado con eso
entonces voy a hacer esto un poco más
pequeño este lazo no quieres que sea
demasiado grande porque va a tocar el
otro lado pero tampoco quieres que sea
tan pequeño
se sigue saliendo no está funcionando
entonces voy a
voy a apretar esto con las pinzas de
punta y voy a doblar completamente este
polo para qué
para ver si se mantiene ya el ac en su
lugar no vamos a arrancar el interruptor
y quitar el pegamento
a ver si esto funciona porque está
bastante complicado entonces quito todo
el pegamento y vamos a tomar el
interruptor colocarlo ahí directamente y
vamos a
a tomar las pinzas de punta y vamos a
hacer aquí el dobles para que se
mantenga ahí está ahí no funciona
cómo le hacemos aquí veamos no hay
cuidado vamos a utilizar el tercer brazo
para que nos apoye con esto que parece
imposible pero no lo es
observa ahí está ya quedó con el tercer
brazo todo se puede y bueno mientras
está aquí sin moverse esto vamos a
saludarlo de una vez
entonces soltamos
aquí vamos a conectar esto el cable
blanco con este interruptor
pues ya ya quedo
muy bien de hecho como que le hace falta
un poco de soldadura entonces otra vez
vamos a calentar el cable blanco para
que la soldadura se derrame un poco más
porque hace falta así que caliente el
cable blanco y
ahí quedó bien entonces bueno así así es
como queremos que se vea esto
ajá ahora puedes ver que las luces leds
funcionan ahí ya tienes los ojos para el
robot y ahora
vamos a pagar esto y vamos a hacer la
otra conexión vamos a conectar este otro
carro y blanco al otro polo del
interruptor
y se nos facilitará más porque ya
tenemos el interruptor en el tercer
brazo entonces vamos a colocarlo con las
pinzas las pinzas nos ayudarán
a colocarlo ahí
quede bien
ahí ya quedó y de una vez vamos a
soltarlo para que quede en su lugar
entonces caliento de este cable blanco y
la soldadura se derrama directamente
ahora coloquemos silicón caliente aquí
en esta esquina de
del estuche de batería para colocar
nuevamente nuestro interruptor que se
había despegado y vamos a presionar para
ayudar a mantener en su lugar mientras
el silicón caliente se enfría entonces
presiona por un rato hasta que se seque
y un poco de paciencia no tarda tanto en
estar esto y después colocamos más
silicón caliente sobre los cables para
que se mantengan en su lugar y
eventualmente también esto ayudará a que
el interruptor también se mantenga en su
lugar no se vuelva a despegar ahora voy
a esperar a que el pegamento obtenga
este color medio blanco porque eso
querrá decir que el pegamento ya está
frío o que ha secado otra cosa que
podemos hacer para que esto funcione
mejor de hecho puedes ver qué funciona
súper bien
está corriendo libremente nuestro robot
pero algo que podemos hacer para que
funcione mejor es primero lo apago y
después voy a tomar otro clip
lo desdobló voy a cortarle aquí un
pedazo no es necesario que esté así de
largo entonces desdoble el clip le cortó
un pedazo y a este pedazo que vamos a
tener aquí
este pedazo vamos a formar un tipo de
cola para nuestro robot y esto le
ayudará a que tenga menos fricción
entonces lo coloco así aquí
y acá es por aquí abajo de hecho lo que
puedes hacer para que quede mejor
vamos a voltear esto y vamos a quitar
una de las baterías quito una batería
después colocó el clip
hacia adentro después colocó otra vez la
batería y ya queda mejor posicionado